so on all my videos about being a cycle breaking parent or a respectful parent
there inevitably are comments from people who say well I don't know about you
but my kids are scared of me and they act right
or I got time out and I got beaten and I turned out just fine
so here's my parenting hot take
there are three general routes you can take with your style of parenting
the easiest is permissive parenting
you just ignore your child's bad behavior and make it everybody else's problem
the second easiest in my opinion is authoritarian parenting
because it is effective
because if you threaten someone with physical violence
they will a lot of the times submit to your rule
that doesn't work for everyone however
because there are types of people who would rather watch the world burn
than submit to authoritarian methods
and then the third and the most hard is gentle or respectful parenting
however that is the most psychologically sound for the child being brought up
now permissive parenting gets mistaken for gentle parenting all the time
and I would agree a lack of boundaries and structure is not great for kids
but the people who believe in authoritarian parenting
that beating your kid
or threatening them with time out to tell them to suck it up and stop crying
is gonna somehow produce a better generation of people
I would like to remind them that there are criminals and crazy people
and bad eggs and absolutely average
every generation
including the generations who got their asses beat
and I'm truly of the belief that you cannot beat the bad out of someone
but you can absolutely beat the bad into somebody
so although we do not threaten our kids with their physical safety
I can assure you that they still can follow boundaries
rules and are fabulous members of society
because in my opinion
if you threaten to spank your kid
you're taking the easy way out